we led the show talking about philip
rivers retirement
and uh the man who broke that news uh in
the san diego union tribune
uh with one of the best five word leads
you'll ever see he wrote and this
summed it all up quote unquote the time
has come
dad gummit kevin acey here on the rich
eisen show outstanding kevin that was
that
i laughed out loud when i read your
first line of your story
i didn't think it could be anything else
but thank you rich of course it summed
it up perfectly
um so did you just get a call last night
from phil or has this potentially been
in the hopper and
it was decided this day it would be done
can you walk me through
uh how this all came about if you don't
mind yeah he gave me he gave me a call
last night
and you know i was expecting at some
point uh
that that might happen but i never
talked to him about it i since
i got off the the you know i was a
columnist actually at the end of his
time
uh but uh since i stopped uh really
writing about the chargers when we talk
i've kept it real
kept it real more like between friends
and and all that but i had a feeling he
was gonna give a call
he actually spent the first five minutes
uh talking about the padres in their
offseason
and for a minute i'm thinking maybe he's
just checking in and then uh
he he said that uh he was gonna retire
and he wanted me to break it
no kidding so that's where you grab your
pen and pad or record something or
that's when you like
say let me get something ready here is
that how that works kevin that's amazing
yeah this was i mean while this was the
big one
and i was somewhat shocked at first i
said look
i think this is great because i know if
you made this decision and i know you're
at peace with it and then of course you
know
basically um i didn't even ask questions
as you know
phillip just talked and so uh he was
free really we've always been on the way
where he trusts me to put down my
thoughts or you know to organize his
thoughts and put it into a story
and uh you know like he texted me
afterward and was like you know like old
times
and and that's what it was um honestly
it says so much about philip that he
called up the guy
who covered him because you know of his
affinity for san diego
and that's how he wanted it to be broken
uh i just i just wouldn't expect
anything different from him
uh i i i know it gets the news because
we throw words
these absolute words around uh but he is
a great human being
kevin ac here on the rich eisen show he
is and and and the way i summed it up
uh to start the show kevin is uh the
ultimate gamer
the ultimate gamer all he wanted was a
helmet and pads that's all he wanted and
10 other guys that would follow his
infectious love of the game
and and and like a child like literally
like
like like a kid who gets to get out
there at age seven age eight he just
happens to be age 37.
you know like like that's the way uh i
i will always remember philip rivers the
ultimate gamer never out
never out of a game always fighting to
the last second i just
i love the guy i love watching him play
yeah i think you nailed it there's two
ways that philip has not changed from
the first time
that i met him you know 17 years ago
and one of them is that he's a really
good guy he is who he
is and to me that just man there just
aren't many people like that
and the other is what you said he loves
to play
and he had a lot of fourth quarter
comebacks and a lot of fourth quarter
tries that
that fell short and yeah he but he was
always in it and i'll tell you
he never thought he was out of it of
those whatever it was i think 240
straight starts i i think he didn't
finish only
a couple of them uh it didn't matter
what the score was philip was going to
play
i'm going to ask you the million dollar
question kevin acey san diego union
tribune
uh former beat rider of the chargers now
columnist and broke the story of philip
rivers retirement right here on the rich
eisenhower million dollar question sir
um and if you had the answer obviously
you you you might be in the town where
uh the raiders currently play so uh why
why didn't philip win at all what's the
what what would be the answer to that
question
when when when the conversation about
his hall of fame worthiness comes up
well no rings
so why why didn't philip win it all
the chargers there was a lot of bad luck
if you think about
in uh 2006 marlon mccree's fumble
after the chargers had seemingly uh
we're just about to ice the game
phillip was also hurt then 2007 he
played in that championship game
against the patriots uh without an acl
had had uh you know surgery the next
week um
he made he didn't play his best in the
postseason there were times where
for all that we could talk about how
great he was and he was
arguably uh one of the top two or three
quarterbacks in the league for a good
three four year period there uh last
decade
um you know he made mistakes he threw
some inopportune uh passes
that were intercepted but he'd you know
when his offense was really good
sometimes their special teams was
monumentally bad i think philip had
bad luck i i remember doing stories on
why hasn't this happened
especially when eli manning the guy he
was training for one
two and i believe a lot of people around
the league who felt
their situations were uh reversed that
phil would have his his hardware
and uh eli manning very well might not
so uh pound the table who's gonna be the
one pounding the table for phillip in
the hall of fame
um room who who's gonna be the who's the
southern california representative with
chargers ties that could do that
because is that going to be you are do
you have a vote for that sort of thing
kevin or who would be that
i was in the room but i i don't anymore
i'll spend my time covering baseball
i'm not sure who it will be uh i'm not
sure how
they uh moved on to to replace me since
the
chargers are no longer in san diego
there haven't been a whole lot of people
that watched it there
uh that have been watching them long
enough in los angeles
if i were making the the argument i
would uh have a whole bunch of stats and
also say the things that i did and have
testimonials from the guys who
uh played with him and played against
him uh
i do know having been in that room the
emphasis that is placed
by a lot of voters rightly so maybe
overly so for some
but on championships and i do know that
it's going to be
an uphill climb for philip uh maybe the
first year the first couple years
well if it's not an up co uphill climb
in the first year um
kevin could you imagine him and breeze
going in together what would that be
i mean could you imagine if i told you
that ever that it's possible
did you like 2004
with blueberries when they threat they
drafted well they dropped eli manning
and then traded right away from philip
and if philip rivers had reported the
camp on time
drew brees almost certainly would not
have got his shot with the chargers
and then drew did what he did
was the great sports stories of all time
the belief drew brees has in himself and
what he turned that into
so yeah wow i i might even go
and um i mean i imagine i will anyway
but uh that would really be special and
not to be you know
um i guess overly dramatic but i've got
that
uh gene in me uh kevin acey um uh
gates is retired uh now it's philip uh
lt is already in the hall
uh is this the end of the san diego
chargers i mean who might there be
out there is it keenan allen right i
mean like who
who can carry this on word now or is
this it
do you think kevin keenan was just
getting to be keenan when they were in
san diego
i think that for a lot of san diegans
this is it
uh first you know he went to play for
the colts but there was still
uh heck this might be it for the nfl for
some san diegans uh but philip
was the tie that kept a lot of chargers
fans
uh involved in the chargers and in the
league so
i think symbolically yeah
this is it and how philip is going to be
a dynamite coach isn't he right i mean
his dad coached him and now uh right now
what these kids are getting at st
michael uh catholic high school
in alabama in terms of my gosh
can you imagine the trash talk that is
going to be happening in him and these
teenagers
this is gonna probably be cleaner than
the teenagers right
oh he'll he'll it'll be cleaner and he
won't tolerate anything different
but i just anybody who's seen any of the
the videos anybody who's watched the
chargers practice
um you have to be so creative to be
that good and not say the f word and
his trash talk is just fantastic and
sometimes it's even
uplifting it puts it down almost up i
just honestly
you you touched a button there because i
i cannot imagine what these kids are
going to be able to experience and it's
pretty amazing his dad coached him he's
going to end up coaching his son in a
couple years
uh for offer all that he ever wanted to
be an nfl quarterback
i i know you're not going to believe me
but right up there
in his goals and his dreams was being a
high school football coach
well now he's going to live that dream
out and kevin i mean your everyone
should seek out your
your your scoop and your story because
it does perfectly
capture philip rivers and so did jj
watts tweet i don't know if you saw it
but
you would talk about his helpful smack
talk him telling a story about that he
pointed out to one of the texans
linebackers telling him he was lined up
wrong based off the blitz we were about
to run and being 100
correct about it and then the last line
i think sums it up about philip one of
the smartest i've ever played against
and a hell of a competitor
that is a perfect way to put it from jj
watt
you know and then jj watt i believe sent
a furlough tweet where he put
asterisk heck of a which i assume was in
respect to phillips
kevin thanks for the call great scoop
let's uh let's stay in touch certainly
since you're talking baseball and uh
we'll talk padres because uh you guys
you guys have got some generationally
talented people on one team
how about that for the san diego padres
it's exciting
it suits a little bit for the san diego
fans i really appreciate it man right
back
that's kevin ac everybody should uh
check it out at sdut
kevin ace on twitter to see his story
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here